so much for cd lamb going to the arizona
cardinal despite the lobbying by kyla
murray to get his former oklahoma
teammate pass catcher into the mix that
includes deandre hopkins and larry
fitzgerald the cardinals with the eighth
overall pick though isaiah simmons the
jack of all trades on the defensive side
of the ball from clemson five different
positions where he has lined up during
the course of his college career it
gives the cardinals flexibility and
versatility and it may have contributed
to him falling as far as he did to
number eight there was concern that you
don't really know where to put him he
doesn't really stand out and there were
some that were thinking that maybe he
would fall even farther but the guy's
just too good to ignore and for as
dynamic as the carnival's offense will
be with tyler murray moving forward the
defense could be very dynamic as well
because now they have a guy who can stay
on the field all the time and if an
offense decides to go no huddle they can
put isaiah simmons anywhere that they
want to in order to create a response to
whatever the offense is trying to do so
an exciting pick for the arizona
cardinals will see if his skills
translate to the nfl level will have
plenty more reaction to the first round
of the 2020 draft as the night continues
to unfold
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports